les gens sont vraiment allés chercher
dans les dents les choses qui pour eux
étaient vraiment symbolique de cette
taille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les sociétés ont un grand intérêt sur
les objets de la vie quotidienne en
général le musée fait partie de ceux là
il s'intéresse aux problématiques
contemporaines il s'intéresse notation
est quotidienne et donc il était assez
naturel que le cem cherche un moyen de
documenter cette période que nous
traversions on va donc décidé de lancer
un appel collaboratif participatif qui
était d'autant plus intéressant que le
sujet toucher l intime des gens et que
leur permettre de s'exprimer à travers
la collecte matériel était aussi en plus
pour documenter les objets et pas
simplement s'arrêter à leur côté
anecdotique genre a conduit très
largement à l'appel et très vite moi
c'est ce qui m'a vraiment surprise vient
des premiers week-ends et l'apprendre la
fin de la première semaine on avait
vraiment déjà beaucoup beaucoup de
propositions qui arrivait aujourd'hui on
a quasiment 600 propositions
on n'est pas du tout sur une seule
typologie d'objets des grandes
catégories auquel on pouvait s'attendre
mais il ya vraiment une inventivité et
les choses qui est témoin d'une capacité
de création d'adaptation au contexte qui
est extrêmement empreinte
alors évidemment on pouvait s'attendre à
certaines catégories d'objets les
masques les attestations de sortie tout
ce qui est l'arsenal de protection
visière gants et autres
c'est présent dans les propositions bien
évidemment mais c'est pas majoritaires
il ya les objets qui marque la durée et
la transformation notre rapport au temps
alors des calendriers les joueurs sont
marrés des cahiers de menu dans lequel
on va à mon inscription à présent ce
qu'on fait ce qu'on mange les agendas
des plannings d'activités des plannings
d'activités sportives parfois avoir même
à des tableaux de quel lieu de calories
dépensées
on a les objets aussi qui parle d'un
rapport différent à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur les gens vont proposer des
plans qu'ils ont fait de leur
appartement
des photos qui témoignent de
réaménagement fait au cours du temps des
photos aussi de l'extérieur puisque la
fenêtre devient une sorte de point de
vue qu'on avait peut-être pas l'habitude
d'avoir mais on va regarder par sa
fenêtre
maintenant différemment feeling et
prendre des photographies différentes
heures du jour
regardez les animaux qui passent ce
rapport intérieur extérieur il est très
très présent dans les propositions avec
une sous-catégorie intéressante que
celle des chaussures qui revient
vraiment que ce soit les chaussures
d'intérieur les chaussons on a des
propositions que sur fait pour sortir
simplement pour aller se promener ou
courir ou pour aller travailler et avec
une proposition particulier que j'ai
trouvé vraiment très touchant très
émouvante d'un infirmier libéral qui
montre comment sa paire de chaussures
reste le soir à l'entrée s'ils ne
rentrent pas avec lui et et réenfiler
lendemain matin la frontière intérieure
extérieure elle est vraiment très
sensibles à travers
[Musique]
on a bien sûr les objets de
manifestations en soignant sa c'est une
catégorie très présente les banderoles
attaché aux fenêtres mes casseroles ou
les cuillères en bois qui servent à
faire du bruit pendant une manifestation
de 20 heures voire des objets qu'on a
bricolé spécifiquement pour faire le
maximum de mouvement non non il ya une
catégorie aussi dans la série un peu
comme ça des inventions qui revient des
objets dont on n'avait pas usage à
vendre qui sont devenus nécessaires
alors du fil qui permet de déambuler les
lunettes
quand on porte un masque et lunettes à
la tyrolienne qui va permettre de relier
deux immeubles qui se font face pour ce
passé qui le sel qui des mots fléchés ou
autre ou la tondeuse à cheveux qu'on va
brancher directement à l'aspirateur de
manière à éviter l'éparpillement des
petits chevaux partout dans la salle de
bain de classe est vraie capacité de de
se débrouiller avec ce qu'on a sous la
main les gros fûts pour les enfants et
le peuple fut pour les parents arrivent
et vivable il ya une ensemble de
propositions aussi qui va traiter de la
modification des relations sociales
donc c'est l'explosion des photographies
de téléphone des captures d'écran et une
news ou autres mais aussi avec un retour
à des choses peut-être plus classique un
retour de la correspondance écrite par
exemple qui revient dans plusieurs
propositions
[Musique]
on voit déjà assez nettement voilà
qu'est une grande capacité de réaction
que les gens ont peut être un peu sonné
dans les premières dans les premiers
jours du confinement n'est que très vite
la vie s'est réorganisée et qu'on va
effectivement pouvoir
réinventer des actions quotidiennes des
activités et méthodologies de travail
aux jeans famille il ya une proposition
très drôle de contrat quand couple a
fait en dix ans mais voilà les limites a
pas dépassé on va être enfermés ensemble
x tend donc à la moindre limite on
sonnera à la petite alarme et on
essaiera de se recadrer
tu m'as fait de la place dans son
appartement est dans ton coeur je pub et
ces témoignages matériels ils sont pas
simplement des choses anecdotiques
permettant de retracer une sorte de
contexte domestique du confinement
ce sont vraiment les témoins de cette
réorganisation assez profonde de nos
modes de vie pendant la période du bon
film on n'a vraiment pas lancer la
collecte dans l'objectif d'une
exposition est vraiment dans l'objectif
d'un enrichissement notre de deux
collections contemporaines
plus j'avance dans l'analyse et ses
propositions plus je me dis que ça
serait quand même bien d'avoir une forme
de restitution sous la forme d'une
petite exposition parce que parce que ça
s'y prête parce que ce sont cent des jo
de gérer à la fois du quotidien mais qui
prennent un sens différent dans le
contexte qu'on a traversées qui du coup
d'oeil quand même à ses parents et à
tout le monde
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]